from the A7 Pawn now it truly is and I
do see King D5 King uh C4 on Liam's
agenda o but why did he put his
Bishop okay the KN has to come to F just
a little bit of Hiccup uh now H4
ISAT yeah no and now King D3 no he
walked into
a andam but does he have enough that D3
pa3 isn't this a queen though my D6
could be on night G5 yeah oh my God and
the players are playing on increment but
this King Pawn ending has to be lost
because black sking is so close to B4
but you have to give it up you don't
have an option you have give that up no
that was a very fortunate blunder very
fortunate blunder but now it's going to
be A different race Tanya who's winning
it looks like black should be faster
with the bwn advancing way faster way
faster F and that's it what a game